[Music]
let's go let's have y'all
[Laughter]
he spent 20 minutes but you know that's
an easy fix though isn't it you know
just undo the hinges
pull the door off yeah afterwards but in
that moment
he's probably thinking am i going to
have to take all he's hot he's sweating
he spent an hour fitting the toilet and
all of a sudden he sees a problem
hey that's bad that is how heavy
concrete is mate
watch it again look this geezer in the
blue he's got no shoes on he's in
concrete now gonna get blisters
that's so dangerous he deserved that
[Laughter]
we sent him down the road he must have
gone too much on the road
you've got being some sort of video
that's going to bump it
what is he doing
i remember my labourer doing that as
well do you know that he actually went
up and down a road for about 10 minutes
trying to start one of them
straight away to paint hold up there
ain't the cleverest
hey what's going on
[Music]
[Laughter]
why would you stand on something you're
trying to break
yeah okay back garden back garden
extension lead it's not spot the hazard
isn't it this is that spot to have
what's going to go on it's like when you
do your driving test and you're looking
for an incident to happen
he's going to kick it and he's going to
go straight through it no chance
yep
[Laughter]
did he clock yeah and watch him stand up
so he might don't know what happened
well don't worry mate i'll carry on is
it yeah i'm gonna go
yeah i look like pretending it didn't
happen if she's come off she's gone
this way's like what's going on mate
he was never kicking that wall no
there's no chance no he's trying to take
the top layer off yeah
but he's just misjudging i don't think
he had his glasses on he mustn't love
working together on a building site he's
like having him it's like yeah being
when you're a woman every day
and sometimes you just want to jump on a
scaffold and let her fall through it
yeah
[Music]
you